deciding on the perfect ending for a
movie can be tough filmmakers have to
end their stories on just the right
notes our audiences might go home angry
and sometimes that can involve a lot of
trial and error case in point
these flicks which underwent dramatic
changes in the endings Department die
hard with a vengeance finds John McClane
going toe-to-toe with Simon Gruber a
riddle loving terrorist with a grudge
after dropping a bunch of bombs and
brainteasers
McClane discovers that Gruber is
actually more interested in stealing a
hundred and forty billion dollars in
gold bullion than blowing anything up so
along with his reluctant sidekick Zeus
Carver McClane tracks Gruber down but
finds himself in a tricky situation when
the bad guy gets both a machine gun and
a helicopter thinking on his feet
McClane shoots a power line and the
falling cables bring down Gruber's
chopper and that's it for most fans of
the franchise it lacks the satisfying
personal touch that made the showdown in
the first I heart so memorable but
that's not for lack of trying
in the original ending Gruber escapes to
Europe with all the gold where he's
living the easy life when an angry
McClane shows up in this version McClane
has been kicked off the force as the
feds suspect him of helping Gruber but
now the ex-cop wants revenge
he puts a Chinese rocket launcher one
missing the directional arrows on the
table between them and he starts asking
Gruber questions the terrorist doesn't
know which way the weapon is aiming and
when he finally gets a riddle wrong he's
forced to pull the trigger
sure unfortunately for Gruber it's aimed
straight at his chest and boom goes the
terrorist it was a pretty epic ending
but according to screenwriter Jonathan
Hensleigh the studio thought it was
quote too cruel admittedly it would have
been a dark mood for McClane but it does
make a somewhat more satisfying showdown
starring Michael Douglas and Glenn Close
fatal attraction was a massive hit when
it was released in 1987 it was the
second highest-grossing film that year
picked up six Oscar nominations and
introduced audiences to Alex Forrest the
seventh best villain of all time
according to the American Film Institute
however this thriller might not have
been so popular if the filmmakers had
stuck with the original ending if you're
not familiar with
plot fatal attraction is about a married
man named Dan Gallagher who has an
affair with the aforementioned
Alex Forrest when he tries to end the
relationship Alex goes a little psycho
and attempts to murder Dan's wife before
she can do the deed dan tries to drown
her in a bathtub and then his wife
finishes Alex off it's a violent climax
to a twisted thriller and audiences ate
it up however the original finale was
far kinder to miss Forrest in his
alternate ending dan is framed for
murder but Alex eventually writes a
letter that frees him from blame Alex
Forrest is dead
sorry test audiences were appalled they
wanted blood and even though close and
director Adrian line were opposed to
changing the ending paramount executive
Ned Tannen ordered the filmmakers quote
to terminate them with extreme prejudice
released in 2017 happy deathday tells
the story of tree a college student
caught in a Groundhog Day style time
loop of course trees predicament is a
lot worse than being stuck in a sleepy
Pennsylvania town with Ned Ryerson she's
being stalked by a masked killer and
every time she dies her day starts over
and she has to face the mysterious
murderer yet again eventually trie
realizes the killer is spoiler alert her
sorority sister Laurie and after eating
a poisoned cupcake she defeats Laurie
and breaks the loop it's a satisfying
ending but the flicks original finale
wasn't quite as hopeful in this
alternate version tree is actually
murdered in the final few seconds by the
wife of the professor she was having an
affair with the film implies she'll be
stuck in the time loop for a long long
time do you really think you'd get away
with screwing my husband
gotta be kidding me
test audiences hated it director
Christopher Landon explained the cinema
blend audiences were like wait she did
all this hard work and made all these
changes and she's a better person now
and then you kill her again on top of
all that land and originally intended
for there to be two killers Lori and
Gregory Butler the professor tree was
messing around with but at the end of
the day he went with just one villain
and made sure that tree would never get
caught in a time loop again until part
two anyway when it comes to movies which
dramatically changed endings the most
infamous of the bunch has got to belong
to Little Shop of Horrors directed by
Frank Oz this musical finds Rick Moranis
playing Seymour a geeky florist in love
with his blonde bombshell of a co-worker
Audrey and his quest to impress her
Seymour begins raising a Venus flytrap
he names Audrey too but as Seymour
quickly discovers this is no normal
plant not only can this thing talk it
also feeds on human blood and it gets
bigger with every meal a couple of
corpses later Audrey too is gigantic and
plans on devouring Seymour and his
ladylove and this is where the original
and that theatrical endings diverge and
wildly different directions in the
original version Audrey too takes
sadistically and devouring our two
heroes even worse a whole bunch of flesh
hungry flowers starts spreading across
the world they grow to gigantic sizes
chase frightened citizens and destroy
every building in sight it's an
incredibly impressive sequence with some
truly staggering puppet work according
to the dissolve the climax cost five
million dollars of the film's 25 million
dollar budget but when Little Shop was
screened for test audiences as oz put it
quote the theater became a refrigerator
an icebox audiences went icy cold the
moment Audrey 2:8 Seymour and his
hapless girlfriend so the filmmakers
scrapped the plant pocalypse and let the
two heroes live happily ever after that
is if they manage to ignore this little
guy right here The Evil Dead franchise
isn't known for its upbeat endings the
first movie finds ash Williams dragged
off by a demon and Evil Dead 2 sends our
screaming hero back to the Middle Ages
army of Darkness on the other hand
ends on a much happier note after
defeating an army of spirits and
skeletons ash escapes the dark ages by
drinking a potion and saying some magic
words he winds up back in the modern day
working at a department store and
killing one last Deadite that hitched a
ride into the future
however this wasn't the ending that
director Sam Raimi intended originally
ash was supposed to drink six drops of a
magic potion one for each century and
then he'd fall into a long slumber when
he woke up he'd be back in the present
however as he's counting out the drops
ash gets distracted loses count drinks
too much and wakes up in a
post-apocalyptic future the world has
been reduced to rubble and it's too much
for ash to take Universal Pictures
wasn't crazy about this grim nd so Raimi
gave us the epic s Mart battle instead
granted the alternate finale is more in
line with the nihilistic tone of the
series but watching ash go pull John
Wayne on a Deadite is pretty awesome so
we're not complaining about studio
interference this time directed by Edgar
Wright Scott Pilgrim vs. the world is an
action-packed romantic adventure where
basically Michael Cera disses Captain
Marvel gets in a bass battle with
Superman and exchanges blows with
Captain America all in a quest to date
the girl of his dreams ramona flowers
playing the titular scott pilgrim
sara has to defeat Ramona's seven evil
exes if he wants to win her hand one by
one he beats them into oblivion and
finally gets to date the rainbow hair
object of his affection sadly that means
he leaves his ex-girlfriend knives ciao
but she seems okay with Scotts choice
who to cool me anyway
Chalmers Co in the original ending
however things took a very different
turn after Scott beats Ramona's final
boyfriend Gideon and the film culminated
in Ramona walking off into the distance
as Scott's and knives rekindled their
romance bond buying stuff yeah and stuff
evidently this was so controversial that
people at test screenings actually
started arguing about it so the
filmmakers use their one-up to start
over and film a new end a third possible
ending would have made fans lose their
minds right briefly considered a
last-minute twist where we learn
everything that it just happened was
part of Scott's deranged fantasy and
that the slacker was actually a serial
killer who just murdered seven innocent
people whether you think Scott should
have wound up with knives or Ramona we
can probably all agree it was wise for
Wright to skip this crazy ending loved
it or hated the ending of the force
awakens is definitely one of the most
memorable in the Star Wars franchise
after hearing so much about Luke
Skywalker Rey finally finds the Jedi
Master on the island of Ock two as the
John Williams music starts to swell Rey
offers the bearded Knights his long-lost
lightsaber man then we cut two credits
it's a classic ending reintroducing
audiences to a beloved hero however the
last Jedi quickly and pretty
controversial II subverts that ending
when Luke grabs the lightsaber and
tosses it into the ocean after making a
grave mistake involving his nephew kylo
Ren Luke has been trying to cut himself
off from the force hoping the Jedi Order
will die with him
interestingly this character arc ends up
changing the original ending of the
force awakens as JJ Abrams had initially
intended to end his film with the Jedi
Knight showing off his otherworldly
powers according to Mark Hamill the
force awakens was supposed to end with
Rey discovering Luke on off to where he
would be surrounded by floating boulders
no doubt a cool nod to the Empire
Strikes Back however before the force
awakens hit theaters Hamill was reading
the last Jedi script and realized the
force awakens ending didn't match up
with Jedi's new direction so he called
up the filmmakers to see what was
happening fortunately the folks at
Lucasfilm had picked up on the problem
and altered the ending before the film
hit theaters
Loki's death and Avengers infinity war
sparked a lot of controversy among
Marvel fans but this wasn't the first
time the god of mischief had met his
maker in the original cuts of Thor the
dark world Loki is actually killed in
his battle with all groan the monster
itself with a bad attitude
so when Thor and Loki say their
heartbreaking goodbyes the one so
hysterically parried even thor ragnarok
sorry I tried to rule I'm sorry about
this thing with the tesseract I just
couldn't help myself that was supposed
to be for real
however Loki fans weren't going to stand
idly by and let the MCU get away with
murder as Tom Hiddleston explained on
the Empire film podcast in test
screenings the audiences didn't accept
it there was a very strange and almost
unanimous resistance to it so Marvel was
forced to change the ending of the film
revealing that Loki was alive and well
and looking a lot like Anthony Hopkins
while it might have felt like a cop-out
at the time it wonderfully set up
everything that happened in Ragnarok so
this is one time where test audiences
did a marvelous job directed by
Alexander Payne 1999's election is a
black comedy with an infamously cynical
ending Matthew Broderick plays Jim
McAllister a high school teacher who
absolutely hates one of his students the
overeager and narcissistic Tracy Flick
played by Reese Witherspoon of course
McAllister isn't exactly the most mature
dude in the room as he's a grown man
trying to sabotage the ambitions of a
high school student so when he's caught
rigging the election for student body
president against Tracy
he's promptly fired from his job in the
theatrical ending McAllister moves to
New York becomes a museum tour guide and
then does a little site scene in
Washington DC that's when he spies Tracy
working alongside some prominent
politician infuriated at her success he
throws a soft drink at her car before
running in the other direction however
there was actually a far sweeter ending
which if you'll believe it was
discovered on an early VHS work print
purchased at a flea market in 2011 in
this original ending McCallister and
Tracy actually let bygones be bygones
pardon the quality like we mentioned
this clip was discovered on a VHS from
the 90s
you know I was having some personal
problems last year and I guess I took it
out on you in this alternate ending
McAllister never moves to New York
instead he's still in his hometown
working as a used car salesman Tracie
shows up looking for a vehicle and the
two start bonding McAllister apologizes
for his bad behavior and even consoles
her when she admits she's worried about
going to college
Tracie then asks McAllister to sign her
yearbook and the film ends as the ex
teacher starts writing dear Tracie
needless to say this didn't go over well
with test audiences as the sweet nd
didn't mesh with such a satirical film
this is one boat that went the right way
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorites topper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]